okay I've got to start today by revising
a previous analysis that I've made I now
believe that it is possible possible but
it is still going to be an uphill battle
for Democrats to take control of the
Senate in 2020 really good post about
this on our subreddit from user homie
Alex seven and homie Alex is completely
right the reality has changed so our
analysis has to change so if you've
heard me talk about this previously I've
said that there is a very real chance of
removing Donald Trump from the White
House in 2020 that's the presidential
election that in the House of
Representatives where Democrats
currently have control there is a very
real chance that Democrats could extend
their majority above and beyond where it
is now but I said that when you look at
the Senate and you look at the seats
that are up for re-election in 2020 that
it didn't seem plausible that Democrats
could take control of the Senate and
really we'd be looking at 2022 is the
first serious opportunity where
Democrats could take control of the
Senate but the good news if you want
Democrats to take control is that there
are now some specific races that have
changed where it is still an uphill
battle but Democrats can take control of
the Senate in 2020 so we're gonna get
into exactly what races these are and
we'll do the analysis and then really
after we do the case-by-case the the
race by race analysis as it may be it'll
be important to do sort of a more
overarching step back look at it because
a lot of times it's not about individual
races it's about the general way that
the the election will go so quickly
catching up there are 100 seats in the
Senate - per state there are six year
terms in the Senate every two years
about a third of those hundred seats are
up for election next November class -
they have classes one two and three
splitting the hundred seats up into
three classes class two is up for
re-election that's 33 seats and then in
addition to those 33 seats there are two
special elections one is in Arizona to
fill the vacancy left by the death of
Republican Senator John
McCain there is also a special election
in Georgia because senator Johnny
Isakson who's also a Republican is
resigning at the end of this year so of
the total 35 seats that are up in 2020
Republicans have 23 seats to defend and
Democrats have 12 seats to defend many
of the Democratic seats are safe for
Democrats Massachusetts for example
Oregon is another one many of the
Republican seats are equally safe for
Republicans like Louisiana and Montana
for example but the balance of power
often ends up depending on a small
number of races and there is now a path
that is not an outrageous one for
Democrats to take the Senate so right
now
the hundred and sixteenth Congress
Republicans of 53 seats Democrats have
45 plus two independents that tend to
caucus with them it's Bernie Sanders and
I believe it's angus King 53 to 47
effectively Democrats needing fournette
seats to take over control putting them
at 51 and Republicans at 49 the other
scenario is that if Democrats take the
White House the vice president becomes
the tie-breaking vote in the Senate
meaning Democrats could have a net gain
of three that would make it 50/50 and
then the vice president who would
presumably be a Democrat if Donald Trump
is defeated would become the
tie-breaking vote in the Senate that's
another scenario so first things first
before we look at what seats Democrats
could take from Republicans are there
any current Democratic seats that could
be lost or are likely to be lost to
Republicans and the answer is yes there
are the one that comes to mind is doug
jones in alabama right now this one is
likely to be lost to a republican doug
jones defeated Roy Moore the serial
accused child sex assault her in a
special election down in Alabama at the
end of 2017 if indeed doug jones is
defeated and he could win but the
polling doesn't look good for Doug that
would mean Democrats
to take back five seats in order to net
a gain of 4 or 4 plus winning the white
house to have the tiebreaker so are
there four or five seats that Democrats
could take from Republicans and the
answer is that yes they are in no
particular order Colorado Colorado is
currently held by Republican Cory
Gardner
we have former presidential candidate
Hickenlooper John Hickenlooper who's
running there he's up according to the
latest poll I found by 13 points that's
one seat that is likely to go from
Republicans to Democrats seat number two
this is one of the ones that's changed
recently Susan Collins because I believe
at least partially her loud support for
Supreme Court justice Brett Kavanaugh
Susan Collins in Maine could be defeated
now she is losing popularity she's still
doing well in the Senate polls but she
could lose this is one where the ground
game is what will determine what happens
but it's potentially winnable and it's
more winnable than it's been in a long
time Susan Collins has been in that seat
since 1997 that's 22 years and this is
probably her most vulnerable re-election
campaign yet that would be seat number
two number three Arizona there's that
special election in Arizona for John
McCain's seat martha mcsalley was
appointed there she has not won an
election astronaut Mark Kelly is running
against her in a recent poll mark Kelly
is plus two over martha mcsalley the
prior poll had him even it's close but
he's in it that would be seat number
three number four now we're getting a
little more speculative tom tilling in
north carolina this is day I'm sorry
Tillis this is definitely one that is a
bit more of a stretch the polling still
has Tillis ahead by about three but he's
not super popular and North Carolina is
a place where we have seen Republicans
move away from approving of the job that
Trump is doing more than in many other
places which means that
it could be winnable in North Carolina
that's four seats and then number five
is Iowa absolute total lunatic
Republican Joni Ernst is still polling
plus two or three in Iowa her popularity
is down significantly she's cuckoo for
cocoa puffs and it is also potentially
winnable so those are the five homey
Alec's seven on our subreddit also
points out there are some longer shots
like if you look at Georgia where the
Republican is only plus five you could
look at Texas John Cornyn is not super
popular I've said what if meadow
O'Rourke were to abandon the race for
the presidential nomination because he
has no chance and get down to Texas
could he defeat John Cornyn so those are
a little more speculative but this is
potentially winnable in 2020 now to be
thorough there's one other Democratic
seat that is not super safe and that's
jeanne Shaheen in New Hampshire the
polling is very close we've got to work
on that one as well we have to hope that
the incumbent Democrat will ultimately
ultimately pull away so these races
require work and the important thing to
now if we one do a more macro analysis
this is looking at it race by race the
reality is that the general pro or anti
Trump sentiment pro or anti Republican
sentiment is likely to have a more
general effect so it's not you know if
Texas ends up being in play it's
probable that North Carolina is winnable
and Iowa is winnable etc if Trump's
popularity goes back up if Republican
attitudes towards Republican incumbents
research then it's likely a lot of these
will not go our way but still if you
want to get involved in an individual
race all you can do is work that race
and if you live in any of these states
even if you don't and you can still
phonebank this one's going to require
work but 2020 the Senate is winnable